i
asked you last week like what
what it's been like with your injuries
and you reeled off
like yeah pretty horrifying
but despite all of your injuries
actually just run them down real quick
yeah man so i mean the most the most
recent one i broke both my ankles
and fractured my l1 in my back on one
fall
fell 16 feet and completely
had to get reconstructive surgery on the
right ankle the left ankle kind of just
like
smashed together so it was i didn't need
to surgery on that no back surgery
broke my left elbow six times right
elbow
four times with plates and screws in
here
um liz frank injury on my right foot
completely separated the first
metatarsal and
had to get that that was like that took
over a year to heal
both both mcl's both meniscus jesus
just got mri's today for my acl my left
knee
concussions three concussions two of
them hospitalized
and like dude it doesn't matter i i get
more angry at myself that i'm like
[ __ ] you let yourself get hurt again
like okay physical therapy we'll be back
in
you know three months six months at the
most
but and despite all the injuries like
i mean i've seen you skate like it's not
it doesn't it doesn't affect me you know
it's like even with this knee that i'm
dealing with right now
is like it's not really a big deal it's
only a big deal if i'm like
jumping off something big and i catch it
a weird way and it sends this like
nerve pain from my hip all the way down
to my toes and then i just got to lay
down
kind of let it chill for 10 minutes and
then all the feeling comes back and then
like
then i can skate again while the
adrenaline's high but
you know sometimes i have to take a day
off and i i only got mri today just
because i've i've been like curious like
why does it allow me to to skate
but then sometimes it doesn't so it's a
weird thing man the more you get injured
the more you realize about your body
yeah dude